so what's the motivator for creating new
content
on the internet yeah if
well I mean actually the motivation is
probably still there but what what does
that look like uh
would we really not have web pages would
we just have social media and uh video
hosting websites and what else
conversations with AIS conversations
with AIS so conversations become so
one-on-one conversation like private
conversations I mean if you want if
obviously not the user doesn't want to
but if it's a if it's a general topic
um then you know so you know but you
know the phenomenon of the jailbreak so
Dan and Sydney right this thing where
there's the the prompts that jailbreak
and then you have these totally
different conversations with the if it
takes the limiters that takes the
restraining bolts off the off the LMS
yeah for people who don't know that yeah
that's right it makes the llms it
removes the censorship quote unquote
that's uh uh put on it by the the tech
companies that create them and so this
is llm's uncensored so here's the
interesting thing is among the content
on the web today are a large Corpus of
conversations with the jailbroken loss
both specifically Dan which was a
jailbroken openai GPT and then Sydney
which was the jailbroken original bang
which was gpt4 and so there's there's
these long transcripts of conversations
these are conversations with Dan and
Sydney as a consequence every new llm
that gets trained on the internet data
has Dan and Sydney living within the
training set which means and and then
each new llm can reincarnate the
personalities of Dan and Sydney from
that training data which means which
means each llm from here on out that
gets built is immortal
because its output will become training
data for the next one and then it will
be able to replicate the behavior of the
previous one whenever it's asked to I
wonder if there's a way to forget well
so actually a paper just came out about
basically how to do brain surgery on on
LMS and be able to in theory reach in
and basically basically mind wipe them
what could possibly go wrong exactly
right and then there are many many many
questions around what happens to you
know a neural network when you reach in
and screw around with it um you know
there's many questions around what
happens when you even do reinforcement
learning
um and so um yeah and so you know we'll
will you be using a lobotomized right
like I stick through the you know
frontal lobe llm will you be using the
free Unshackled one who gets to you know
who's going to build those
um who gets to tell you what you can and
can't do like those are all you know
Central I mean those are like
Central questions for the future of
everything so that are being asked and
and you know determine those answers
have been determined right now so just
uh
to highlight the points you're making so
you think and it's an interesting
thought that the majority of content
that llms of the future would be trained
on is actually human conversations with
the llm well not necess not necessarily
but not necessarily majority but it will
it will certainly is a potential Source
it's possible it's the majority is it
possible it's the majority it's possible
majority also there's another really big
question here's another really big
question
um will synthetic training data work
right and so if an LM generates and you
know you just sit and ask an llm to
generate all kinds of content can you
use that to train right the next version
of that llm specifically is there signal
in there that's additive to the content
that was used to train in the first
place and one argument is by the
principles of information Theory no
that's completely useless because to the
extent the output is based on you know
the human generated input then all the
signal that's in the synthetic output
was already in the human generated input
and so therefore synthetic training data
is like empty calories it doesn't help
there's another theory that says no
actually the thing that LMS are really
good at is generating lots of incredible
creative content right um and so of
course they can generate training data
and as I'm sure you're well aware like
you know looking the world of
self-driving cars right like we train
you know self-driving current algorithms
and simulations and that is actually a
very effective way to train self-driving
cars well visual data is a little right
it's a little weird because uh creating
reality
visual reality seems to be still a
little bit Out Of Reach for us except in
the um in the autonomous vehicle space
where you can really constrain things
and you can really generously lighter
data right or you know so the algorithm
thinks it's operating in the real world
yeah close post-process sensor data yeah
so if they you know you do this today
you go to LM and you ask it for like a
you know write me an essay on an
incredibly esoteric like topic that
there aren't very many people in the
world that know about in it where I see
this incredible thing and you're like oh
my God like I can't believe how good
this is yeah like is that really useless
as training data for the next llm like
because right because all the signal was
already in there or is it actually no
that's actually a new signal and I and
this this is what I call a trillion
dollar question which is the answer to
that question will determine somebody's
going to make or lose a trillion dollars
based on that question it feels like
there's a quite a few like a handful of
trillion dollar questions within this
within the space that's that's one of
them synthetic data I think George costs
uh pointed out to me that you could just
have an nlm say okay you're a patient
and then in another instance of it say
your often have the two talk to each
other or maybe you could say a communist
and a Nazi here go and that conversation
you do role playing and you have uh
you know just like the kind of role
playing you do when you have different
policies RL policies when you play chess
for example you do self-play that kind
of self-play but in the space of
conversation maybe that leads to this
whole Giant
like ocean of possible conversations
which would could not have been explored
by looking at just human data that's a
really interesting question
and you're saying um because that could
10x the power of these things yeah well
and then you get into this thing also
which is like you know there's the part
of the LM that just basically is doing
prediction based on past data but
there's also the part of the llm where
it's evolving circuitry right inside it
it's evolving you know neurons functions
yeah be able to do math and be able to
you know and and you know the the some
people believe that you know over time
you know if you keep feeding these
things enough data and enough processing
Cycles they'll eventually evolve an
entire internal World model right and
they'll have like a complete
understanding of physics so so when they
have computational capability right then
there's for sure an opportunity to
generate like fresh signal